This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When Leon Flaisher was a small child, his older brother took piano lessons. The brother didn't much care for them. But afterwards, little Leon would climb onto the piano bench and play, note for note, the pieces his brother had practiced. That's when his mother realized Leon was the one who should study the instrument. Leon Flaisher made his debut at Carnegie Hall in 1944. He was just 16 years old.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。当莱昂·弗莱舍还是个小孩子时，他的哥哥在上钢琴课。哥哥其实不太喜欢弹琴。但下课后，小莱昂会爬上琴凳，把哥哥练习的曲子音符不差地弹出来。就在那时，他的母亲意识到莱昂才是那个应该学习这门乐器的人。1944年，莱昂·弗莱舍在卡耐基音乐厅首次登台演出。当时他年仅16岁。
Who is to perform Brahms, piano concerto number one in D minor? A New York Times music critic said this performance established him as one of the most remarkably gifted of the younger generation of American keyboard artists. He went on to perform with the world's top orchestras throughout the 1950s and early 60s. Pause the story here and Leon Fleischer's life is a triumph. But then something unexpected happened. He started to notice an odd stiffness in his right index finger.
谁将演奏勃拉姆斯的降D小调第一钢琴协奏曲？一位《纽约时报》的音乐评论家曾表示，这场演出确立了他是美国年轻一代键盘艺术家中最具非凡天赋的人之一。在整个20世纪50年代和60年代初，他继续与世界顶级管弦乐团合作。如果把故事在这里暂停，莱昂·弗莱舍的人生堪称一场巨大的胜利。但随后，意外发生了。他开始注意到自己右手食指有一种奇怪的僵硬感。
His fourth and fifth finger started curling under. The pain and stiffness grew steadily worse. Within a matter of months, his career as a concert pianist was virtually over. As you can well imagine without becoming melodramatic, it was, I was in a very despairing state of depression for about two years. If we were to take stock of Leon Fleischer's life at this point, we might say it was a tragedy. But Leon Fleischer still had so much music in him, so he reinvented himself, becoming a much admired conductor and teacher.
他的第四个和第五个手指开始向内蜷缩。疼痛和僵硬感不断恶化。在短短几个月内，他作为音乐会钢琴家的职业生涯几乎宣告结束。正如你所能想象的那样，并不是在夸大其词，那是——我在大约两年的时间里处于一种非常绝望的抑郁状态。如果我们在此刻盘点莱昂·弗莱舍的人生，我们可能会说这是一场悲剧。但莱昂·弗莱舍心中依然有着如此多的音乐，于是他重塑了自我，成为了一位备受推崇的指挥家和教师。
Meanwhile he continued to try every available measure to heal his right hand. Eventually a combination of Botox injections and deep tissue massage started to help. In 2003 Leon Fleischer made a triumphant return to Carnegie Hall. He was 75 years old. The next year, he released a CD, his first 200 recording in over 40 years. Today, we kick off a month-long series that we are calling Healing 2.0. We look at the nature of loss and also a mind-bending idea about whether we should try to do away with grief altogether. Plus, we explore whether trauma really does make us stronger and how to craft an apology.
与此同时，他继续尝试所有可能的方法来治疗他的右手。最终，肉毒杆菌注射和深层组织按摩的结合开始发挥作用。2003年，莱昂·弗莱舍在卡耐基音乐厅迎来了胜利的回归。当时他已经75岁了。第二年，他发行了一张CD，这是他40多年来首次录制唱片。今天，我们开启了一个为期一个月的系列节目，我们称之为“疗愈2.0”。我们探讨了失落的本质，以及一个关于我们是否应该彻底消除悲伤的颠覆性想法。此外，我们还将探讨创伤是否真的能让我们变得更坚强，以及如何巧妙地道歉。
This week on Hidden Brain, how the way we understand the ups and downs of our lives can shape the ups and downs of our lives. As we make our way through life, it can feel as if we are buffeted by a swiftly moving series of events. Sometimes it's all we can do to keep our heads above water as we wait for the next wave to crash over us. But research and psychology hints at a different process unfolding beneath the waves, an undercurrent that has powerful effects on our well-being, mental health, and life outcomes. At Olden College, psychologists Jonathan Adler studies how our minds are shaped by this
本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨我们如何理解生活中的起伏，如何塑造我们生活中的起伏。在我们的人生旅程中，感觉自己仿佛被一连串快速移动的事件冲击着。有时候，我们能做的全部就是在等待下一波浪潮向我们砸来时，拼命把头露出水面。但心理学的研究暗示，水面之下正在展开一个不同的过程——一股对我们的幸福感、心理健康和生活结果产生强大影响的潜流。在欧登学院，心理学家乔纳森·阿德勒研究了我们的心灵如何被这种
undercurrent, and how becoming mindful of it can help us better deal with setbacks and failure. Jonathan Adler, welcome to Hidden Brain. Jonathan Adler, I'm so excited to be here with you. Jonathan, I want to take you back to your college days in Maine. You're a capable and hardworking student, but you were also struggling with a secret. What were you going through? Yeah, like you said, I was a good student.
潜流所塑造，以及如何意识到这一点能帮助我们更好地应对挫折和失败。乔纳森·阿德勒，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。乔纳森·阿德勒，我很高兴能和你在一起。乔纳森，我想带你回到你在缅因州的大学时代。你是一个能干且勤奋的学生，但你也在和一个秘密作斗争。你当时经历了什么？是的，就像你说的，我是一个好学生。
I was curious and took classes in a ton of different departments. But socially, I was more reserved. I had a really tight group of friends in high school and I was sort of angry that that chapter of my life had closed just because high school had ended and I was also struggling with my sexuality, though that's not something I was necessarily conscious of for a big chunk of college. So you came up with a solution to these challenges and it was something of a radical solution. What was the plan you devised?
我很好奇，在许多不同的系里上了课。但在社交方面，我比较内向。我在高中时有一个非常紧密的朋友圈，我有点生气，仅仅因为高中结束了，我人生的那一章就合上了，而且我也在跟自己的性取向做斗争，尽管这并不是我在大学很大一部分时间里必然有意识到的事情。所以你为这些挑战想出了一个解决方案，而且这是一个相当激进的解决方案。你设计了什么计划？
Yeah, well, so a lot of students at the college spent part of their junior year studying abroad. And that seemed to me like a rare opportunity to take a break from my regular life and figure out some things about myself. So I ended up in Perth, which is on the west coast of Australia. Wow. Which it's literally as far away from my life as you could get. I mean, if you draw a line from New England through the center of the earth, you end up off the coast of Perth.
是的，所以学院里的很多学生在大三的一部分时间里都在海外留学。这对我来说似乎是一个难得的机会，可以从我的日常生活中抽离出来，弄清楚关于我自己的某些事情。所以我最终去了帕斯，它在澳大利亚西海岸。哇。这简直是我生活中能去到的最远的地方了。我的意思是，如果你从新英格兰画一条穿过地球中心的线，你最终会到达帕斯海岸附近。
And this was your way of reinventing yourself. Well, it felt like an opportunity to step outside my life and sort of explore who I was in a context that wouldn't then have any ramifications for the life that I was living. So, okay, so you fly all the way to Australia. What happens? Did you find that your social life improved, that you found deep connections with other people? No. When I arrived, I knew that I was going to need to find some friends. So I auditioned for the theater department's play. I was studying psychology and theater in college and I knew that being involved in a show was a surefire way to make fast friends and that it also was a place where there might be opportunities
这是你重塑自我的一种方式。嗯，这感觉像是一个走出我的生活，在某种程度上探索我是谁的机会，而这种探索不会对当时我正在过的生活产生任何影响。所以，好吧，你一路飞到澳大利亚。发生了什么？你发现你的社交生活改善了吗，你与其他人找到了深厚的联系吗？没有。当我到达时，我知道我需要找一些朋友。所以我去试镜了戏剧系的戏剧。我在大学里学习心理学和戏剧，我知道参与一场演出是结交新朋友的绝佳途径，而且那也是一个可能会有机会
to date. And so the play that the department was a place where there might be opportunities to date. And so the play that the department was doing that semester was this weird postmodern adaptation of Chekov's classic Uncle Vanya by the admittedly brilliant British playwright Howard Barker. And there's this relatively minor character in the original play Asterov, who's this brooding intellectual who just thinks but never does anything, and I figured, oh, that's perfect for me. But much to my astonishment, I got cast as Vanya,
去约会的地方。所以系里那个学期排演的剧目是契诃夫经典作品《万尼亚舅舅》的一个奇怪的后现代改编版，改编自公认才华横溢的英国剧作家霍华德·巴克尔。原作中有一个相对较小的角色阿斯特罗夫，他是一个沉郁的知识分子，只思考却从不付诸行动，我想，哦，这太适合我了。但令我大跌眼镜的是，我竟然被选中饰演万尼亚，
which is one of the only leading roles that I'd ever had. Wow. Yeah, so most of Chekov's plays are about people who are stuck in their lives and sort of consumed with what might have been the joke about Chekhov is that nothing ever happens. And so this playwright Barker took this play and decided to imagine what would happen if the same characters just did whatever their impulses told them to do. So in this version there are gun battles and unconstrained sex and a whole lot of chaos,
这是我演过的仅有的几个主角之一。哇。是的，所以契诃夫的大多数戏剧都是关于那些生活受困、沉浸在“本来可能会怎样”的人，关于契诃夫的笑话就是什么事都不会发生。所以这位剧作家巴克尔拿过这部剧，决定想象一下，如果这些角色只是做他们的冲动告诉他们要做的事，会发生什么。所以在这一版中，有枪战、无节制的性爱和大量的混乱，
it's total liberation. And I was an anxious actor, and so having to carry this play in a role that was deeply unsuited to my natural tendencies, was all consuming. I had gone looking for the kind of liberation that these characters were given by their playwright, but in finding it in
这是彻底的解放。而我是一个焦虑的演员，所以不得不挑起这部剧的大梁，扮演一个极不符合我天性的角色，这让我全神贯注。我曾去寻找这些剧作家赋予角色的那种解放，但在找到它时
this fictional world, it completely shut down my own world. I felt I had to spend my time mastering this incredibly complex and unnatural language. I mean, the first line of the play is just the word uncle repeated over and over, and I just lost all the bandwidth for everything else. It ended up being one of the loneliest periods of my life with me actually starting to count down the days until I could come home. And what I had envisioned as a time for freedom and exploration actually became this burdened lonely time and I think it set me back in the process of coming out.
在这个虚构的世界里，它彻底关闭了我自己的世界。我觉得我必须把时间花在掌握这种极其复杂且不自然的语言上。我的意思是，剧中的第一台词就是“舅舅”这个词一遍又一遍地重复，我失去了处理其他一切事物的带宽。这最终成为我一生中最孤独的时期之一，我甚至开始倒计时，直到我能回家。我曾设想为自由和探索的时光，实际上却成了负担重重、孤独的时光，我认为这阻碍了我的出柜进程。
And I think it set me back in the process of coming out. So you returned to Maine after the semester abroad. You're back now in the same college where you were previously frustrated. What goes through your head at this point? I think I felt profoundly disappointed in myself for not having capitalized on this rare opportunity and stifled to be back in my old life without having figured anything out and Yeah, so I think I just sort of put my head down and kept doing what I knew how to do which was be a brain not a fully integrated body a fully integrated body. Jonathan's time in Australia felt like more than a misadventure. It felt like a sign.
我认为这阻碍了我的出柜进程。所以你在海外留学学期结束后回到了缅因州。你现在回到了之前让你感到沮丧的同一所大学。这时候你脑子里在想什么？我想我对自己深感失望，因为没有充分利用这个难得的机会，而且回到旧生活中感到窒息，却什么也没弄明白。所以，我想我只是把头埋起来，继续做我擅长的事——做一个大脑，而不是一个完全整合的身体，一个完全整合的身体。乔纳森在澳大利亚的时光感觉不仅仅是一次不愉快的经历。这感觉像是一个征兆。
He had made the trip with high hopes, hoping to become a new person. When he returned no different than before, it didn't just feel the same. It felt worse. Many of us have had experiences similar to Jonathan's. We suffer setbacks and failures, humiliations and disappointments. When these happen to us frequently enough, we start to think that we will never be happy. Never be whole.
他带着很高的期望踏上旅程，希望能成为一个新人。当他归来时与以前毫无二致时，感觉不仅仅是毫无改变。感觉更糟了。我们许多人都有过类似于乔纳森的经历。我们遭受挫折和失败、羞辱和失望。当这些事情频繁发生在我们身上时，我们开始认为自己将永远不会快乐。永远不会完整。
When we come back, why unhappiness can breed unhappiness? And how to break the cycle? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Jonathan Adler spent much of his young adulthood feeling unsatisfied, yearning for more. He sensed he was gay, but didn't feel comfortable coming out. He spent a semester in Australia to break free of the constraints of his college life in Maine, but found that he was just as lonely on another continent.
回来后，我们将探讨为什么不快乐会滋生不快乐？以及如何打破这个循环？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。乔纳森·阿德勒在青年时期的很大一部分时间里都感到不满足，渴望得到更多。他隐约觉得自己是同性恋，但并不觉得出柜很自在。他在澳大利亚度过了一个学期，以打破他在缅因州大学生活的束缚，却发现自己在另一个大陆上同样感到孤独。
Sometime after he returned to the United States, however, Jonathan made a discovery. He came by the work of a pioneering scientist in a field known as narrative psychology. Dan McCatum's at Northwestern University was arguing that the stories we tell about our lives have profound effects on our well-being. Jonathan moved to Northwestern, became Dan's PhD student, and later his scientific collaborator. In time, Jonathan came to see his own life through the lens of his research. He realized that he had been telling the story of his life in a way that was self-defeating, and he came to see that by telling that story differently, it could make a profound difference.
然而，在他回到美国后不久，乔纳森有了一个发现。他接触到了一位被称为叙事心理学领域的开拓性科学家的著作。西北大学的丹·麦克亚当斯提出，我们讲述自己生活的故事对我们的幸福感有着深远的影响。乔纳森搬到了西北大学，成为了丹的博士生，后来又成为了他的科学合作者。随着时间的推移，乔纳森开始通过他的研究视角来看待自己的生活。他意识到，他一直以来以一种自我挫败的方式讲述着自己的人生故事，并且他开始明白，通过以不同的方式讲述这个故事，它可能会带来深远的不同。
We'll get to that in a moment. First, I asked Jonathan to explain to me the basic idea behind narrative psychology. You can't totally control the things that happen to you in your life. You have some more say about how you make sense of it. And it's important to remember we're talking about stories here. So we know from research on memory that we're not very good at recording the objective facts of our experience. For a long time, that frustrated cognitive scientists, but in more recent years, it's become clear that our memory works like this for a good reason. So if you think about why we have memory in the first place, it's not so we can hold on to every single thing that's happened to us in some veritable way, we have memories so that we can make sense of what's happening to us right now and
我们一会儿就会讲到这一点。首先，我请乔纳森向我解释叙事心理学的基本理念。你无法完全控制生活中发生在你身上的事情。你对如何理解它有更多的发言权。重要的是要记住，我们这里讨论的是故事。因此，从记忆研究中我们知道，我们并不擅长记录我们经历的客观事实。很长一段时间里，这让认知科学家感到沮丧，但在最近几年，人们已经清楚地看到，我们的记忆以这种方式运作是有充分理由的。所以，如果你想想我们为什么首先拥有记忆，那并不是为了我们可以用某种真实的方式抓住发生在我们身上的每一件事，我们拥有记忆是为了让我们能够理解此时此刻发生在我们身上的事情，并且
anticipate what might happen next. So if you walk by a cave and a bear jumps out, you don't necessarily need to remember that cave and that bear. But you need to remember that dangerous things might hide in dark places. So the slippery, reconstructive nature of memory is a feature of the system. It's not a bug.
预测接下来可能会发生什么。所以如果你走过一个洞穴，一只熊跳了出来，你不一定需要记住那个洞穴和那只熊。但你需要记住危险的事情可能隐藏在黑暗的地方。因此，记忆易变、重构的性质是该系统的一个特征。它不是一个漏洞。
And stories are an amazing tool for holding on to the meaning of our past experiences. So the objective facts of our lives are what they are, but the stories are about where we draw connections between things, where we parse the chapter breaks of our lives. And those are narrative acts, not historical acts. And the way we do that can have big implications for our well-being. Jonathan and Dan McCatams have found that one of the most crucial choices we make in telling our stories,
故事是保持我们过去经历意义的惊人工具。所以我们生活的客观事实就是这样，但故事是关于我们在哪里画出事物之间的联系，我们在哪里划分我们生活的章节分界线。这些是叙事行为，而不是历史行为。我们这样做的方式可能会对我们的幸福感产生重大影响。乔纳森和丹·麦克亚当斯发现，我们在讲述故事时做出的最关键的选择之一，
and it's important to underscore that most of us make these choices unconsciously, is where we start and stop the different chapters of our life story. All lives have good and bad in it, and so stories that start bad and end bad don't feel great, and stories that start good and end good, those feel good. But what we find in the research is that where we draw connections between the negative and the positive matters a lot. So stories that we narrate as starting bad and ending good, we call that a redemption sequence. And stories that start good and end bad, we call that a contamination sequence. I see. So a redemption sequence is in some ways something bad happens to you, but in some
而且需要强调的是，我们大多数人都是在无意识中做出这些选择的，那就是我们从哪里开始和结束我们人生故事的不同章节。所有的人生都有好有坏，所以开头不好、结局也不好的故事感觉不太好，而开头好、结局也好的故事，那些感觉很好。但在研究中我们发现，我们在哪里画出消极和积极之间的联系非常重要。因此，我们将那些叙述为开头不好、结局变好的故事称为“救赎序列”。而我们将那些开头好、结局变坏的故事称为“污染序列”。我明白了。所以救赎序列在某些方面是你遭遇了坏事，但在某些
ways you're rising from the ashes, redemption. And a contamination sequence is things are going pretty well, but then something bad happens to you and then everything is downhill from there. So one basically has an upward trajectory, the other one has a downward trajectory. That's right. And again, we're remembering these are stories. So this is how we narrate the experience, not necessarily the objective facts of our lives, because all lives have good and bad.
方面你从灰烬中崛起，实现了救赎。而污染序列则是事情进展相当顺利，但接着坏事降临，之后一切都在走下坡路。所以一个基本上呈上升轨迹，另一个则呈下降轨迹。没错。再次提醒，我们要记住这些都是故事。所以这是我们叙述经历的方式，而不一定是我们生活的客观事实，因为所有的人生都有好有坏。
I mean, your story about going to Australia, for example, you know, you go to Australia with high hopes, you get the starring role in a play. Many people would say that's a very good thing to have happened to you. And then the play turns out to not be quite what was best for you, or the role turns out to be not what was best for you. And you end up being very lonely, and then you can sort of see a downward spiral in some ways. And in some ways it becomes a contamination story, a story
我的意思是，例如你关于去澳大利亚的故事，你知道的，你怀揣着极高的期望去澳大利亚，你在一部戏剧中获得了主角。许多人会说，这对你来说是一件非常棒的事情。然后这部戏剧结果证明并不完全是对你最好的，或者这个角色证明并不完全是对你最好的。你最终变得非常孤独，然后你某种程度上可以看到一种螺旋式下降。在某种程度上，它变成了一个污染的故事，一个
where something good turned bad and then you come back to the United States. And now it feels like the bad thing that happened in Australia is with you even now. And that's sort of how contamination works. It has a contagious effect and spreads and infects other things. That's right. And again, I didn't know about Dan's work at that moment in my life, so I wasn't thinking about it in story terms, but indeed, I think I was living out what I can now retrospectively see was a contamination sequence. I want to talk a little bit about the effects of these sequences on our life, the effect of a redemption narrative
好事情变成坏事的故事，然后你回到了美国。现在感觉澳大利亚发生的那件坏事即使在现在也一直伴随着你。这就是污染的作用方式。它具有传染效应，并扩散并感染其他事情。没错。再说一次，我当时并不知道丹的工作，所以我并没有从故事的角度来思考它，但确实，我当时正在经历一段我现在回过头来看是一个污染序列的生活。我想稍微谈谈这些序列对我们生活的影响，救赎叙事的影响
and a contamination narrative. What effects do these different stories have on our lives? What's the difference on our mental well-being and happiness of redemption stories versus contamination stories? I have a nice short example of this from a participant in one of my earliest studies. Briefly, this was a little middle-aged man.
和一个污染叙事。这些不同的故事对我们的生活有什么影响？救赎故事与污染故事对我们的心理健康和幸福感有什么区别？我从我最早的一项研究的一位参与者那里找到了一个很好的简短例子。简单来说，这是一个中年小个子男人。
He's recounting the story of the first date that he went on with the woman that he ultimately goes on to marry. And the facts of the story are they go out when he brings her home. They're standing on her front porch and he leans in for a kiss and then her dad opens the front door and interrupts them. So in the version that this man narrated when he shared his life story as part of participating in our research, he frames the experience as a redemption sequence. He says, it really brought us close right at the very start of our relationship and we
他在讲述他和最终与之结婚的女性进行第一次约会的经过。故事的事实是，他们外出约会，然后他送她回家。他们站在她家的前廊上，他俯身去亲吻她，接着她的父亲打开前门打断了他们。因此，在这名男子在参与我们的研究时分享他的人生故事所叙述的版本中，他将这段经历构建为一个救赎序列。他说，这确实在我们的关系刚开始时就把我们拉近了，而且我们
stayed that way ever since. So this embarrassing moment had given them something to laugh about on their second date and maybe it accelerated their connection. But he might have narrated the exact same sequence of events by concluding that it was this stain on the beginning of their relationship that could have contaminated the relationship in a way that they moved on from, but never could erase. So neither version is more accurate in the historical sense. These are narrative interpretations that take on different thematic arcs, redemption and contamination, but these different ways of narrating our lives have different implications for your well-being.
从那以后就一直保持着这种状态。所以这个尴尬的时刻让他们在第二次约会时有了一个可以拿来开玩笑的话题，也许这加速了他们的关系。但他本来可以叙述完全相同的事件序列，得出的结论是，这是他们关系开始时的一个污点，本可以以某种方式玷污这段关系，虽然他们向前看了，但永远无法抹去。因此，从历史意义上讲，没有哪个版本更准确。这些是呈现出不同主题弧线的叙事解释，即救赎和污染，但这些叙述我们生活的不同方式对你的幸福感有着不同的影响。
We find over and over that when redemption sequences occur in people's life stories, they tend to be associated with positive well-being, good life satisfaction, lower levels of things like depression, higher self-esteem, and it's just the opposite for themes of contamination. So what's important here, and you've mentioned this before, is that the underlying facts of the story don't have to change for the story, in fact, to be a very different kind of story. So, for example, in your own life, you're still a, you know, gay man coming of age at a time when homophobia is rampant, you're still lonely in college, the Australia trip was less of an escape and more of a setback, but you can tell both a contamination
我们一次又一次地发现，当人们的人生故事中出现救赎序列时，它们往往与积极的幸福感、良好的生活满意度、较低水平的抑郁等负面情绪、更高的自尊心联系在一起，而对于污染主题则恰恰相反。所以这里重要的一点是，你之前也提到过，故事的基础事实不需要改变，这个故事实际上就可以变成一种非常不同类型的故事。所以，例如，在你自己的生活中，你仍然是一个，你知道的，在一个恐同现象猖獗的时代成长的同性恋男子，你在大学里依然感到孤独，去澳大利亚之旅与其说是一次逃避，不如说是一次挫折，但你可以围绕这些事实讲述一个污染故事
story as well as a redemption story built around those facts. That's right. And again, the shift there is about where we draw the chapter breaks in my life. So if we end that story, end that chapter when I get back to college, it feels like a contamination sequence. But if I string it together with the things that came next, spoiler alert, it feels like a redemption sequence. Tell me what happened next and how it becomes a redemption story. As I neared the end of college, I largely dealt with my internal turmoil by just throwing myself into my work.
以及一个围绕这些事实构建的救赎故事。没错。再说一次，这里的转变在于我们在我的生活中划分章节的位置。因此，如果我们结束那个故事，在我回到大学时结束那一章，它感觉就像是一个污染序列。但如果我把它和接下来发生的事情串联起来，剧透一下，它感觉就像是一个救赎序列。告诉我接下来发生了什么，以及它是如何变成一个救赎故事的。随着大学接近尾声，我基本上是通过全身心投入工作来应对内心的动荡。
So I was one of the top students in my class and I got some awards and I took a research job after college at Harvard, which was, you know, my plan was going to graduate school. And I felt like I had done everything expected of me. And I didn't really seek out any mentorship as I applied to 10 very competitive PhD programs. And then when the whole process was done, I only got into one program. So I always tell students, you only go to one school. So it only takes one. And that is true. But at the time, it felt like a shock. Don't get me wrong, I was actually really excited by the one option in front of me,
所以我是班里的顶尖学生之一，我获得了一些奖项，大学毕业后我在哈佛找到了一份研究工作，你知道的，我的计划是读研究生。我觉得我已经做了所有对我期望的事情。当我申请10个竞争非常激烈的博士项目时，我并没有真正寻求任何指导。然后整个过程结束时，我只被一个项目录取了。所以我总是告诉学生，你只去一所学校。所以只需要一个。确实如此。但当时，这感觉像是一个打击。别误会我，我其实对眼前的这唯一选择感到非常兴奋，
but I had sort of imagined that I might have more choice when approaching this next big chapter of my life. And as you said, the one school I got into was in the Midwest, a place that I had never been for more than a few days. And so I was thinking a lot about what it would mean to be a gay man living in this different part of the country than I was used to.
但我原本想象着，在接近我人生下一个大章节时，我可能会有更多的选择。正如你所说，我被录取的唯一一所学校在中西部，那是一个我从未呆过超过几、三天的地方。所以我当时想了很多，作为一个同性恋男子生活在一个与我习惯的该国其他地方不同的地方，究竟意味着什么。
So how does this become a redemption story? I'm still, it sounds actually the contamination is getting worse here because you apply to all these colleges and you don't get into them. Right. So here's what happened. So I went to campus for my interview and it was spring break week.
那么这怎么会变成一个救赎故事呢？我还是觉得，听上去污染似乎在这里变得更严重了，因为你申请了所有这些大学却没有被录取。没错。事情是这样的。我去校园面试时，正值春假周。
So no one was really around. But after the formal stuff was done, I sort of casually walked by the LGBT student groups office and there was this little yellow envelope of business cards tacked to the bulletin board outside that said something like questions, email us and then you know some generic email address. So when I got home, I sent this email saying, I'm thinking of coming here for graduate school.
所以基本上没什么人在。但在正式的事情结束后，我顺便溜达着经过了LGBT学生组织的办公室，外面公告栏上钉着一个小黄信封，里面装有名片，上面写着类似“有问题请给我们发邮件”的话，然后你知道的，是一个通用的电子邮箱地址。所以当我回到家时，我发了这封邮件，说：“我正在考虑来这里读研究生。
I've never lived in the Midwest. What's it like to be there and be a gay person, both on campus and in the surrounding community? And we didn't even have internet at the house that I was renting with some friends. So I had to sneak into the computer lab at the nearby college to check my email. So a few days later, I got a perfectly nice and very thorough email reassuring me from a senior undergrad about what it was like to go to school there and live in the town. And I'm sure it was a copy and paste of an email that he had sent many times before, but sure.
我从未在中西部生活过。那里的生活是怎样的，作为一个同性恋者，在校园里和周边社区都是怎样的？”而且我和几个朋友合租的房子里甚至没有互联网。我不得不偷偷溜进附近学院的计算机实验室去查收我的电子邮件。几天后，我收到了一封来自一位大四本科生的非常友好且详尽的电子邮件，让我感到放心，他告诉我那里上学和在镇上生活是怎样的。我确信这是他以前发过很多次的电子邮件的复制粘贴，但当然。
I appreciated how clear it was and the bits of humor sprinkled in. And I wrote back to say, you know, thanks, that was so super helpful. And then this student said, I'm actually graduating early, but I'm going to be hanging around. I'm handing off the list serve, but if you have questions, you know, just send me an email. And so quite a bit of time goes by and I did commit to going to school there. And when it was time for me to start looking for an apartment, I reached out again. And more than 20 years later, we are now married
我很感激它的清晰明了以及其中点缀的幽默感。我回信说，你知道，谢谢，这太有帮助了。然后这位学生说：“我其实要提前毕业，但我会在这里呆一段时间。我要把邮件列表交接出去，但如果你有问题，你知道的，就给我发个邮件。”就这样，过了相当长的一段时间，我确实决定去那里上学。当我要开始找公寓时，我又联系了对方。20多年后的今天，我们现在已经结婚了
and have two kids in a dog. So those first emails weren't even remotely flirty, but they were attuned and connected and kind and funny and eventually they did get flirty as did my responses. And so I look back at this churning point in my life with a profound sense of, first of all, gratitude, but also redemption. Right, what at the time felt like close to failure, right, that all my work in college and all my ignoring of my personal life for the sake of my intellectual life had presented
有两个孩子和一只狗。所以最初的那些邮件甚至连一点调情的意味都没有，但它们是合拍的、有联系的、善良的、有趣的，最终它们确实变得带有调情意味了，我的回复也是如此。所以我回首我人生的这个转折点时，首先感到一种深深的感激，但也是一种救赎。对的，当时感觉几乎是一场失败，对我在大学里的所有努力以及为了智识生活而对个人生活的所有忽视，现在只给我提供了一个唯一的选项，而现在感觉就像宇宙在努力确保我找到了自己的道路。不到一年，我就拥有了比我曾经想象过的更令人满足的智力体验，而且我没有坠入爱河。我在想，在某种程度上，叙事重塑是否在这些发生在你生活中的事情中发挥了某种作用？难道只是你经历了一连串的坏运气和坏事，然后你经历了一连串的好运气
me with only one option now feels like the universe trying to make sure that I found my way. And within a year I was having a more gratifying intellectual experience than I had ever imagined, and I wasn't love. I'm wondering in some ways if the narrative changing played some role in sort of these things happening in your life. Is it just that you had a series of bad luck and bad events happening to you and then you had a series of good luck and good events happening to you and then you had a series of good luck
和好事？我的意思是，情况可能确实如此，但从心理学角度来看，这并不是特别有趣。你认为你思考自己生活的方式以及你接触丹的理念，是否重塑了你以不同方式思考关系的能力或意愿，或者思考与某人在电子邮件中调情的能力或意愿？是的，真的——我真的很感激你提出这一点，因为确实，有人可能会说，客观事实是事情很糟糕，然后事情变好了。我们在生活中划分章节的位置真的很重要。所以，是的，有人可能会说，嗯，那段可怕的章节结束了。
and good events happening to you? I mean, that might be the case, but that's not particularly interesting from a psychological point of view. Do you think that the way you were thinking about your own life and your exposure to Dan's ideas was had reshaped your ability or your willingness to be open to thinking about a relationship
而这个新章节只是一个好章节。但我实际上认为，正是由于我将这两段经历交织在我的人生故事中的方式，才让它感觉像是一种救赎。
in a different way or thinking about flirting on email with someone? Yeah, it's really I really appreciate you bringing that up because indeed one could say well the objective facts where things were bad and then things were good It really matters where we draw the chapter breaks in our lives So yeah one could say well that horrible chapter is. And this new chapter is just a good chapter. But I actually think it is the way I have woven those two experiences together in my life story where it feels like redemption.
它不再是一个先坏后好的故事，而是一个关于从孤独和自我封闭转变为职业和个人满足感以及身份认同整合的故事。注意你开始和结束乔纳森故事的地方，对于这个故事到底是救赎故事还是污染故事，有着深远的影响。如果你把他在大学时的不快乐、在澳大利亚的挫折，以及他大学那么努力后却只进了一所研究生院的事实联系起来，这个故事看起来就像是一个无休止的
Instead of being a story where it was bad and then it was good, this is a story that is about a shift from loneliness and compartmentalization to professional and personal fulfillment and identity integration. Notice where you start and stop Jonathan's story makes a profound difference about whether the story is a redemptive story or a contamination story. If you draw a connection between his unhappiness and college, his setbacks in Australia, and the fact he got into only one graduate school after working so hard in college, that story looks like an endless loop of
挫折循环。另一方面，如果你讲述的是这样一个故事：一个孤独、隐秘的同性恋小孩，阴差阳错地考入了唯一一所能让他在职业上成功、个人生活幸福的学校，那么这就好像天空裂开，一颗星星正在为乔纳森指明前进的方向。故事的客观事实没有改变，但你对故事的看法发生了深刻的改变。你可以在威廉·邓拉普和杰西卡·特雷西进行的一项研究中看出这一点有多么强大。
setbacks. On the other hand, if you tell the story of a lonely, closeted gay kid who just happens to get into the one school where he is going to be professionally successful and personally happy, then it looks like the heavens have parted and a star is pointing the way forward for Jonathan. The objective facts of the story don't change, but the way you think of the story changes profoundly. You can see how powerful this is in a study conducted by William Dunlup and Jessica Tracey.
他们当时在研究戒毒人士所讲述的故事。他们研究了个人叙事与在酒精依赖中保持清醒的人之间的关系。因此，他们让参与匿名戒酒互助会的成员讲述他们最后一次喝酒的故事。他们实际上有两个样本，一个是戒酒四年或更长时间的人，另一个是处于戒酒初期阶段的样本。在这两组中，他们发现，讲述他们最后一次喝酒的救赎故事的人比那些故事中不包含救赎主题的人更有可能保持清醒
They were researching the stories told by people fighting addiction. They looked at the relationship between personal narratives and the maintenance of sobriety among people navigating alcohol dependence. So they asked people involved in alcoholics anonymous support groups to tell the story of their last drink. They actually had two samples, one of people who had remained sober for four years or longer, and another sample who were in the earliest stages of sobriety. And in both groups, they found that people who told redemptive stories of their last drink were more likely to stay sober than people whose stories didn't contain redemptive
主题。例如，他们谈到了一位参与者，他觉得对他来说最后一次喝酒真的象征着低谷，这是他承诺真正扭转人生命运的时刻，他随后的确做到了。这正是该领域许多发现的典型代表，有些研究行为，有些主要研究心理健康结果，我们发现我们讲述自己生活的故事是我们表现如何的强有力预测指标。乔纳森还发现，我们讲述生活故事的方式会产生生理影响。在一项研究中，乔纳森追踪了一组承受慢性压力的父母。
themes. So, for example, they talk about one participant who felt like the last drink for him really symbolized the low point, and it was the moment when he committed to really turning his life around, and which he then goes on to do. And that is emblematic of many findings in the field, some that look at behavior, some that look mostly at mental health outcomes, where we find that the stories that we tell about our lives are strong predictors of how we're doing. Jonathan has also found that the way we tell stories about our lives can have biological effects. In one study, Jonathan tracked a group of parents experiencing chronic stress.
他在该研究中的合著者阿什利·梅森对端粒科学很感兴趣。端粒是我们染色体末端的帽状结构，可以保护它们在每次细胞分裂时免于磨损或纠缠，因为每次细胞分裂，端粒都会变得越来越短，最终细胞失去保护并死亡。因此，一些科学家将端粒长度视为衰老的生物标志物。我们知道，在慢性压力的情况下，端粒磨损得更快。因此，在这项研究中，我们有一组承受慢性压力的参与者，他们是育有患有相当严重的自闭症
His co-author on the study, Ashley Mason, was interested in the science of telomeres. So telomeres are the end caps on our chromosomes that protect them from getting frayed or tangled each time a cell divides because each time the cell divides, they get shorter and shorter and eventually the cells left unprotected and it dies. So some scientists see telomere length as a biological marker of aging. And we know that under conditions of chronic stress, telomeres wear down faster. So in this study, we had a group of chronically stressed participants, these were parents who had children with quite severe autism
谱系障碍儿童的父母，我们将他们与神经典型儿童的父母进行了比较，作为一个神经典型儿童的父母，这仍然是一段充满压力的经历，但慢性压力的程度是不同的。因此，我们掌握了他们的故事，在慢性压力的程度上是不同的。因此，我们在研究开始时收集了他们的故事，然后有了他们的幸福感指标以及他们在第一个时间点的端粒长度数据，接着
spectrum disorders, and we compared them to parents of neurotypical kids, which as a parent of neurotypical kids is still a stressful experience, but the degree of chronic stress is different. So we had their stories at the degree of chronic stress is different. So we had their stories at the beginning of the study, and then we had measures of their well-being and also data about their telemier length at that first time point, and then
在18个月后再次测量。我们发现，在这些承受慢性压力的父母中，他们的故事非常重要。有趣的是，这项研究中的关键叙事主题不是救赎。这是一个整合的主题，我们考虑到参与者能够在多大程度上理解拥有这样一个具有挑战性的孩子，并将其整合到他们自己的人生故事中。因此我们发现，在这些承受慢性压力的父母中，整合的故事不仅与他们自我报告的较低水平的心理压力相关，
again 18 months later. And what we found was that among these chronically stressed parents, their stories mattered a lot. What was interesting was that the key narrative theme in this study was not redemption. It was a theme of integration where we think about the extent to which participants were able to make sense of having had this challenging kid and integrating that into their own life story. So we found that among the chronically stress parents, stories of integration were associated not only with their self-report of lower levels of psychological stress,
而且还与18个月内端粒显著减少较少有关。据我所知，这是唯一一项显示人们叙事中的主题与压力和衰老的生物标志物之间存在联系的研究，但这表明我们的故事可能会产生生理后果，而不仅仅是心理后果。父母在他们讲述的故事类型方面说了什么，关于哪些故事是有效的或效果较差的。研究中的一位父母谈到了育儿如何成为终极人生考验，这是她所说的话。
but also with significantly less telomere shortening over 18 months. So as far as I know, this is the only study to show a connection between the themes and people's narratives and biological markers of stress and aging, but it suggests that there may be biological consequences of our stories, not just psychological ones. What did the parents say in terms of the kind of stories they told, in terms of stories that were effective or less effective. One of the parents in the study talked about the ways in which parenting is the ultimate life test as what she said.
她说，你知道，你可以读到大量关于所有这些事情的书籍，但归根结底你必须向你的孩子学习。对她来说，这教会了她很多关于她自己作为一个人的身份，她是开放的还是不开放的，以及她如何感觉到拥有这段具有挑战性的育儿经历确实帮助她重塑了她作为一个人的本质，以及对于她来说，不仅是作为父母，而且是作为一个深爱着另一个人类的人类，这意味着什么。现在，当你听到有人讲述救赎故事并看到他们正在经历更好的心理健康时，会出现一个问题，即因果关系的箭头朝哪个方向运行？你知道，是他们在讲述救赎故事，因此对生活感觉更好，还是他们对生活感觉更好，因此讲述救赎故事，进而对生活感觉更好？或者他们对生活感觉更好，因此在讲述救赎故事？有一阶段，你追踪了一群与心理治疗师合作的病人的治疗过程，你既记录了他们在治疗期间经历的变化，也记录了他们讲述的关于生活的故事，还记录了哪个先发生。你发现了什么，乔纳森？是的，我对那个方向性问题着迷了。在那项研究中，我招募了一群人，年龄在18岁到92岁之间的成年人。
And she said, you know, you can read a ton about all this stuff, but ultimately you have to learn from your kid. And for her, that taught her a lot about who she was as a person, how she was open and not open, and how she felt like having this challenging parenting experience really helped her reshape who she was as a person and what it meant to her to not only be a parent, but a human in relation with this other human who she loved dearly. Now when you hear someone tell a redemptive story and you see that they are experiencing better mental health, there is a question that arises which is in which direction does the arrow of causation run? You know, are they telling redemptive stories and therefore feeling better
他们寻求个人治疗的原因涵盖了极其广泛的问题。因此，有些人患有非常显著的精神病理学问题，比如抑郁、焦虑、进食障碍。但也有人只是想在自己身上做一些工作。有一位女性想理清她自己的童年。她即将成为一名父母。有一位女性在退休生活中感到孤独。
about their lives or are they feeling better about their lives and therefore telling redemptive stories and therefore feeling better about their lives? Or are they feeling better about their lives and therefore telling redemptive stories? At one point you followed a group of patients as they worked with a psychotherapist and you charted both the changes they experienced while in therapy and the stories they told about their lives and also which preceded which. What did you find Jonathan? Yeah, I became obsessed with that directionality question. In that study, I enrolled a bunch of people, adults ranging from ages 18 to 92.
所以在他们开始接受治疗师治疗之前，我们收集了他们的故事，并使用标准测量方法测量了他们的幸福感。因此，在另一端，我们拥有来自所有这些参与者的近600个叙事。我们发现，首先，人们在治疗过程中情况有所好转，这很好，因为几十年的心理治疗研究表明它确实有效。
They were seeking individual therapy for a huge range of problems. So there were folks with really significant psychopathology, like depression, anxiety, eating disorders. But there were also people just wanting to do some work on themselves. There was a woman who wanted to think through her own childhood. She was about to become a parent. There was a woman who was feeling lonely and retirement.
我们发现，在治疗过程中，人们的故事发生了有意义的变化。而且故事的变化实际上先于幸福感的变化发生，而不是相反。因为这就好像人们在讲述他们生活的新版本，然后一两周后他们的幸福感就会赶上这个故事。当我们经历生活，对不可预测地向我们袭来的起伏做出反应时，感觉我们就像生活事件的人质。
So before they started with their therapist, we collected their stories and we measured their well-being, user standard measures. And so then on the other side, we had nearly 600 narratives from across all these participants. And what we found was, first, people got better over the course of treatment, which is good because decades of research on psychotherapy suggests that it works.
这就是为什么许多人在发生在他们身上的事情中看到了命运之手。但一旦我们意识到我们不仅仅是人生故事中一个饱受欺凌的角色，我们也是作者，一切看起来都会有所不同。稍后我们将介绍讲述更明智的生活故事的四个原则。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我们所有人都在不断构建关于我们生活的故事。大多数时候，这是在潜意识中发生的。我们并没有意识到自己所做的叙事选择。然而，每隔一段时间，我们的生活中就会发生一些事情，促使我们重新审视我们的故事：婚姻、离婚、孩子的出生、挚友的去世。所有这些都需要时间来融入我们人生故事的叙事中。
And we found that people's stories changed in meaningful ways over the course of treatment. And then the changes in the story actually came before changes in well-being and not the other way around. Because it was as if people were narrating a new version of their lives and then a week or two later their well-being would catch up with the story. As we go through our lives, responding to ups and downs that come at us unpredictably, it can feel as if we are hostages to life events.
在欧登工程学院，心理学家乔纳森·阿德勒研究了当挑战我们既有叙事的事件出现时会发生什么。约翰，我想让你讲讲一个名叫安妮·布鲁斯特的医生的故事。你能描述一下安妮在20多岁快结束时的生活是什么样的吗？安妮是那种难以置信地有进取心、成功的学生。她曾——在医学院表现极其优秀，找到了一份很好的住院医师工作，工作了无数个小时，但她开始感到身体一侧有些麻木，她去检查了，
This is why many people see the hand of fate in the things that happen to them. But everything looks different, once we realize that we are not simply a beleaguered character in our life story we are also the author. When we come back four principles to tell wiser stories about our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. All of us constantly construct stories about our lives. Most of the time, this happens under the surface. We are not mindful about the narrative choices we make. Every so often, however, something happens in our lives that causes us to revisit our stories, a marriage, a divorce, the birth of a child, the death of a close friend. All of these take time to assimilate into the narrative of our lives.
这就是为什么许多人把发生在他们身上的事情看作是命运之手。但一旦我们意识到我们不仅仅是我们生活故事中一个饱受困扰的角色，我们也是作者，一切都会变得不同。当我们回归四个原则，来讲述关于我们生活的更明智的故事时。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这就是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们所有人都在不断地构建关于我们生活的故事。大多数时候，这是在潜意识中发生的。我们并没有意识到自己所做的叙事选择。然而，每隔一段时间，我们的生活就会发生一些事情，促使我们重新审视我们的故事，比如结婚、离婚、孩子的出生、至亲好友的离去。所有这些都需要时间来融入我们生活的叙事中。
At Olden College of Engineering, psychologists Jonathan Adler has studied what happens when events come along that challenge our pre-existing narratives. John, I want you to tell me the story of a physician named Annie Brewster. Can you describe what Annie's life was like when she was in her late 20s? Annie was one of these unbelievably driven, successful students. She was, had done extremely well in medical school, landed a great residency, was working a million hours, but she had started to experience some tingling on one side of her body, and she went to get it checked out,
在欧登工程学院，心理学家乔纳森·阿德勒研究了当挑战我们原有叙事的事件出现时会发生什么。约翰，我想请你给我讲一个名叫安妮·布鲁斯特的医生的故事。你能描述一下安妮二十多岁晚期时的生活是什么样的吗？安妮是那种令人难以置信的、有进取心的、成功的学生之一。她在医学院表现极其优异，找到了一份很好的住院医师工作，没日没夜地工作，但她开始感到身体一侧有些麻木，于是她去检查了,
and she was very well connected in the medical sphere and waited to see the Uber specialist who quite brusquely told her that she had multiple sclerosis. I want to play a bit of tape here from Annie herself, talking about how she reacted to the news from her doctor. It took me a long time to come to terms with that diagnosis to accept it into my life. Really, it was difficult for me
她在医学界人脉很广，于是她去看了那位顶尖专家的号，那位专家非常生硬地告诉她，她患有多发性硬化症。我想在这里播放一段安妮本人的录音，谈谈她对医生这个消息的反应。我花了很长时间才接受这个诊断，才把它接受到我的生活里。真的，这对我来说很难
because I'd always thought of myself as somebody who was really strong, my body had always worked for me, done what I wanted it to do, and to think of myself as someone with an illness, I really had to redefine myself and get over some denial. Jonathan, you say that Annie was engaging in an internal process of accommodation. What do you mean by this? And is accommodation a good thing?
因为我一直觉得自己是个非常坚强的人，我的身体一直都很听我的话，我想做什么它就能做什么，一想到自己是一个生病的人，我真的必须重新定义自己，并克服一些否认心理。乔纳森，你说安妮当时正在进行一个内在的顺应过程。你这是什么意思？顺应是一件好事吗？
So most of what we do most of the time, we call assimilation. We go on living our lives and when new things happens, we just assimilate those experiences into the story that we've been telling, whether we do that consciously or not. But sometimes something happens that really makes us question the story we've been telling. And in those instances, the story itself needs to change to accommodate that new experience. And what we call a accommodative processing is a key narrative variable in supporting our well-being. But it doesn't support our well-being in exactly the way redemption does, for example.
所以我们大部分时间里做的大多数事情，我们称之为同化。我们继续生活，当新事情发生时，无论我们是否有意为之，我们只是把这些经历同化到我们一直在讲述的故事中。但有时会发生一些事情，真的让我们质疑我们一直在讲述的故事。在这些情况下，故事本身需要改变来顺应这种新体验。我们称之为顺应加工，它是支持我们幸福感的一个关键叙事变量。但它支持我们幸福感的方式并不完全像救赎那样，举个例子。
But accommodative processing, it helps us feel like our life has meaning and we understand it, even if it doesn't always feel good. And so Annie tells this story that once she did finally start to accommodate this experience, when she did really start to reach a experience, when she did really start to reach a per identity to include this idea of herself as having an illness, she stepped away from her very prestigious medical career, she went down to part-time and she founded a nonprofit organization called Health Story Collaborative. And I met Annie about a year into that process and she was going around and collecting other people's stories and curating them. And 10 years later we have worked really
但顺应加工有助于我们感觉到自己的生活是有意义的，并且我们能理解它，即使它并不总是让人感觉良好。所以安妮讲述了这个故事，一旦她终于开始顺应这种经历，当她真正开始接触一段经历，当她真正开始将自我认同转变为包含自己生病这个想法时，她退出了她那个声望极高的医疗职业，转为兼职，并创立了一个名为“健康故事合作社”的非营利组织。我在这个过程大约一年后遇到了安妮，她当时正在四处收集其他人的故事并进行策展。10年后，我们进行了非常
closely together developing programs that leverage the science of narrative in order to support storytelling in the highly fragmented and fragmenting medical ecosystem. When we modify our life stories to accommodate new life events, those events no longer feel random and aboriginal. The less we feel buffeted by random events, the more we feel like we are in control of our own lives. This leads to the next idea. Jonathan has found that stories that give us a feeling that we are in charge of our own lives are linked to high or well-being. Agency is a theme in people's stories.
紧密的合作，开发利用叙事科学的项目，以便在高度碎片化且正在碎片化的医疗生态系统中支持讲故事。当我们修改我们的人生故事以顺应新的生活事件时，这些事件就不再让人感觉是随机和突兀的了。我们越是不觉得自己被随机事件所冲击，我们就越觉得能够掌控自己的生活。这就引出了下一个观点。乔纳森发现，那些让我们感到自己能够掌控生活的叙事与高幸福感息息相关。自主性是人们故事中的一个主题。
We assess it along a continuum from sort of being able to direct your life and then down at the other end of the continuum, you're sort of battered around by the whims of fate. And again, these are themes and stories. No one is completely in control of their lives. So it's the way you portray the main character in the story, i.e. you. Jonathan cites the remarkable Story of a Woman named Leila. So in the last five years, I've been doing a lot of research focused on identity development among people who acquire physical disabilities. And Leila was a participant in one of my studies. She tells this story of having these horrible headaches, which gradually intensified to
我们沿着一个连续体来评估它，从某种程度上能够主导你的生活，然后到连续体的另一端，你某种程度上被命运的变幻莫测所摆布。同样，这些都是故事中的主题。没有人能完全掌控自己的生活。所以关键在于你如何塑造故事中的主角，也就是你自己。乔纳森举了一个名叫莉拉的女性的非凡故事。所以在过去五年里，我做了大量研究，专注于获得性身体残障人士的身份认同发展。莉拉是我的一位研究参与者。她讲述了自己头痛欲裂的经历，这种头痛逐渐加剧到
the point where she couldn't function. She spends time in three different hospitals in Nairobi, Kenya, where she lives. And no one can figure out what's going on. She decides to fly to India to see a specialist, and he sends her right into surgery. And when she wakes up, the pain is gone. But she also can't see, and the surgeon had been able to alleviate the unexplained swelling in her head that had been pressing on her optic nerves, but the nerve was also irreparably damaged.
无法正常生活的地步。她在她所居住的肯尼亚内罗毕的三家不同医院待过。没有人能弄清楚是怎么回事。她决定飞往印度看专家，而专家直接把她送进了手术室。等她醒来时，疼痛消失了。但她也看不见了，外科医生虽然减轻了她脑部压迫视神经的莫名肿胀，但她的视神经也受到了无法挽回的损伤。
So for a few months, everyone held out hope that her vision might return, but Leila was actually the first one to accept that it wouldn't. She said, I realized as soon as I started accepting it, I started becoming less frustrated and sad. And though it was incredibly difficult and scary for her, Leila gradually threw herself into the task of becoming a blind person. So she shifts careers, she moves to the United States to get training and computer science, where she starts working on adaptive technology for other blind and low-vision people.
所以在几个月的时间里，大家都抱有一线希望，希望她的视力能恢复，但莉拉其实是第一个接受它不会恢复的人。她说，我一意识到并开始接受它，我就开始变得不再那么沮丧和悲伤了。尽管这对她来说极其困难和可怕，但莉拉逐渐全身心投入到成为一个盲人的任务中。于是她转换了职业，搬到美国去学习计算机科学，在那里她开始为其他盲人和视障人士开发适应性技术。
I want to play a clip of Lela talking about her experience, Hyeshiyas. I think my blindness is the best thing that ever happened to me. Like, if I had no doctor, I'd give him and told me they have a cure, I would not take it. Because I think for me it made me understand myself and it made me like, it gives me these new challenges every single day. It presents me with something and through those challenges I'm able to understand myself. So, that's a remarkable account, Jonathan. But as I hear Leila talking, I feel like I've heard the same thing in the deaf community. Many deaf people today say, you know, the real
我想播放一段莉拉谈论她经历的剪辑，希什亚斯。我认为失明是我经历过的最好的事情。比如，如果有个医生走过来告诉我他们有解药，我都不会接受。因为我认为对我来说，这让我了解了自己，它让我，每天都给我带来这些新的挑战。它向我呈现一些事情，通过这些挑战我能够了解自己。所以，这是一个非凡的叙述，乔纳森。但当我听到莉拉这样说时，我感觉我在聋人社群里也听到过同样的话。当今许多聋人会说，你知道，真正的
problem is not with deafness. I just happen to speak sign language, I speak a different language than you do. Now, we can all debate how and whether something should be considered a disorder. But I think the point you're trying to make here is that the stories we tell can either put us in the driver's seat or put us in the passenger's seat and Leila is clearly choosing to be in the driver's seat. That's right.
问题不在于耳聋。我只是碰巧说手语，我说的是一种与你不同的语言。现在，我们都可以争论某事应该如何以及是否应该被视为一种障碍。但我认为你在这里试图表达的观点是，我们讲述的故事要么把我们放在驾驶座上，要么把我们放在乘客座上，而莉拉显然选择坐在驾驶座上。没错。
Traditional models of disability in the United States have this medical approach where disability is a problem to be solved or eradicated, and social models of disability or relational models really push back on that and say disability is in the interaction between my body and the built and social environment around us. In Layla's story, like you said, there's also this sense of agency now that this is part of who I am,
美国的传统残疾模式采用这种医疗方法，将残疾视为需要解决或根除的问题，而残疾的社会模型或关系模型则坚决反对这一点，并认为残疾存在于我的身体与我们周围的人造和社会环境的互动之中。在莉拉的故事中，就像你说的，现在也有了一种自主感，既然这是我的一部分，
what am I gonna do with it? How can I take control of this and use it for things that matter to me? You can see a theme emerging here. As you tell the story of your life, do you see yourself as a passive subject, someone to whom things happen, or as an active protagonist, someone who is directing the course of her own life? Now as Jonathan says, every life offers lots of evidence that
我要拿它怎么办？我如何才能掌控它并将其用于对我重要的事情上？你可以在这里看到一个新兴的主题。当你讲述你的人生故事时，你是将自己视为一个被动的受体，一个事情降临到身上的人，还是一个积极的主角，一个掌控自己人生轨迹的人？正如乔纳森所说，每个人生都提供了大量的证据，
allows you to draw either conclusion. Given this, Jonathan is saying, choose narratives that put you in the driver's seat. Most of the narratives we have discussed so far have championed the idea of the individual. But it's also the case that no man is an island. Yeah, so right in our conversation so far we've been very focused on individuals, but of course we aren't these isolated individuals, we're all connected. And communion is a theme that captures the quality of people's connections to others. So in my research with people who have disabilities, there's often a lot of talk about their connections, not only with family and friends and co-workers, but with the broader disability community. but with the broader disability community. So at Olden College, you have organized a yearly event called the Story Slam,
让你得出这两种结论中的任何一种。鉴于此，乔纳森的意思是，选择那些把你放在驾驶座上的叙事。我们迄今讨论的大多数叙事都支持个人主义的理念。但事实也是，没有人是一座孤岛。是的，所以在我们目前的对话中，我们一直非常关注个人，但当然我们并不是孤立的个人，我们都是相互联系的。而共融是一个捕捉人们之间联系质量的主题。所以在我和残疾人士的研究中，经常有很多关于他们联系的讨论，不仅是与家人、朋友和同事的联系，还有与更广泛的残疾社群的联系。但与更广泛的残疾社群的联系也是如此。因此，在奥林学院，你组织了一个名为“故事大满贯”的年度活动，
which students perform renditions of their stories, tell about the events in their lives. And in advance of one year's slam, you worked with a student named Antonio. What was his story, Jonathan? Yeah, so Antonio was really interested in thinking through what it meant to him to be a first generation Latino student at this small engineering college. And he described feeling isolated during his weekend on campus as a prospective student. It wasn't the conversations about science that made him feel left out. It really was the small talk. So he has this great line in the story where he says, I'm definitely not fluent in cheese.
学生们在活动中表演他们的故事演绎，讲述他们生活中的事件。在其中一年的大满贯之前，你与一个名叫安东尼奥的学生合作。他的故事是什么，乔纳森？是的，安东尼奥真的很想思考在这个小型工程学院里，作为一个第一代拉丁裔学生对他的意义。他描述了自己作为准新生在校园度过周末时感到的孤立。让他觉得被排斥的并不是关于科学的对话。真正让他感到格格不入的其实是闲聊。所以在故事里他有一句很棒的话，他说，我绝对不精通“奶酪”。
And what he means is that disconnection gets coded into even the most mundane experiences, not just the grand, low points of our lives. But as isolated as he was feeling, Antonio home then, not on his isolation, but on a moment of connection. I think I finally found somebody who understood Diego was a person who had also danced at Quintiangera's, who had also brought lunch in a repurposed sour cream container, and applied to the same college scholarships for low-income students.
他的意思是，这种脱节甚至被编码到了最平凡的体验中，而不仅仅是我们人生的重大低谷。但尽管他感到孤立，安东尼奥随后关注的，不是他的孤立，而是一个产生连接的时刻。我想我终于找到了一个理解我的人，迭戈也是一个曾在成人礼上跳过舞的人，他也曾用重新利用的酸奶油容器装午餐，并申请了针对低收入学生的同一所大学奖学金。
One would even think we had done all these things side by side. So I can hear the theme of positive communion here, Jonathan. Antonio is telling a story that says, I'm not alone. Exactly. In this room full of people who did not look like him, Antonio found someone who did, and they really connected, and he says, you know, Diego threw down this challenge. If you think there should be more people like us here, then come and fix it. And Antonio says, you know, I'm a competitive guy.
人们甚至会认为我们是一起并肩做完所有这些事情的。所以我能在这里听到积极共融的主题，乔纳森。安东尼奥正在讲述一个故事，它在说，我并不孤单。完全正确。在这个不认识他的人的房间里，安东尼奥找到了一个长得像他的人，他们真正建立起了联系，他说，你知道，迭戈发出了这样的挑战。如果你认为这里应该有更多像我们这样的人，那就来改变它吧。安东尼奥说，你知道，我是一个很有竞争心的人。
And the next fall, I was on a-way bus trip to Olin College. Jonathan, one final feature of a constructive story is that it generates meaning for the person who tells it. You say we're not always able to tell a happy story about what happens to us, but we can try and tell a meaningful story and there are benefits to telling such stories. Can you explain what you mean? Yeah, so to pan back for just a second when we think about the broad study of well-being, it tends to cluster in sort of two domains, which get their cumbersome names from Aristotle. So on the one hand we have what's called hedonic well-being, which means it feels good.
第二年秋天，我坐上了开往奥林学院的大巴。乔纳森，一个建设性故事的最后一个特点是它为讲述者产生了意义。你说我们并不总能讲述一个关于我们遭遇的快乐故事，但我们可以试着讲述一个有意义的故事，而讲述这样的故事是有好处的。你能解释一下你的意思吗？是的，所以退一步来讲，当我们思考关于幸福感的广泛研究时，它往往聚集在两个领域，这两个领域的名字听起来有些拗口，源自亚里士多德。一方面，我们有所谓的享乐型幸福感，这意味着感觉很好。
And on the other hand we have a kind of well-being called Udimonic well-being, which means it feels good. And on the other hand, we have a kind of well-being called udymonic well-being, which means it feels meaningful. And these two domains of well-being are actually relatively uncorrelated with each other. And if we think about our lives for a second, that makes sense, right? We all do plenty of things that feel good, but don't feel particularly meaningful.
另一方面，我们有一种叫做实现型幸福感的幸福感，这意味着感觉很好。另一方面，我们有一种叫做实现型幸福感的幸福感，这意味着感觉有意义。而这两个幸福感领域实际上彼此之间没有太大关联。如果我们思考一下我们的生活，这是有道理的，对吧？我们都会做很多感觉很好，但并没有特别有意义的事情。
We might binge watch TV or something. plenty of things that feel good, but don't feel particularly meaningful. Like, we might binge watch TV or something. And we can all think about experiences that feel meaningful, but don't feel particularly good. So, in my work with Health Story Collaborative in particular, we find that feeling good is not always an option for people. Telling redemptive stories or stories high in the theme of agency and communion, that's not always possible. And in those situations, we're often interested in the ways in which people can really think through the hard parts of their lives
我们可能会狂看电视剧什么的。做很多感觉很好，但并没有特别有意义的事情。比如，我们可能会狂看电视剧什么的。我们都能想到那些感觉有意义，但感觉并不怎么好的经历。所以，尤其是在我和“健康故事合作社”合作的工作中，我们发现感觉良好对人们来说并不总是一个选项。讲述救赎色彩的故事，或者具有高度自主和共融主题的故事，并不总是可能的。在这些情况下，我们通常感兴趣的是人们如何能够真正深入思考他们生活中的困难部分，
and find some meaning out of that. And even if the meaning doesn't ultimately feel good in that sort of happy sense, that meaning is still incredibly worthwhile. I'm trying to imagine how someone who is going through a rough time might hear this episode Jonathan, and I worry that that person might say, you know, I've just lost my job, I've just gotten divorced, I've just lost my job, I've just gotten divorced,
并从中找到一些意义。即使这种意义最终在那类快乐的意义上并不让人感觉良好，这种意义仍然非常值得。我在想象一个正在经历艰难时期的人会如何看待这一集，乔纳森，我担心这个人可能会说，你知道，我刚失业，我刚离婚，我刚失业，我刚离婚，
I've just lost a close family friend. And now Jonathan Adler comes along and tells me that if I'm unhappy, it's because I'm not telling the right story about my life. How would you respond to that? I want to say three things to that person. The first thing is, I'm sorry. I'm sorry that things are so hard for you right now.
我刚失去了一位亲密的家庭朋友。现在乔纳森·阿德勒出现并告诉我，如果我不快乐，那是因为我没有讲述关于我人生的正确故事。你会如何回应？我想对这个人说三件事。第一件事是，我很抱歉。我很抱歉你现在过得这么艰难。
Of course, they're hard, and of course, you're not feeling good. The second thing I want to say is there are all kinds of ways of making meaning of these experiences. And so we might think about exploring themes of agency or communion. So if you lost your job, are you feeling connected to your spouse or your kids, or you know if something challenging has happened might there be some growth that comes from it. So we might explore those themes. But the third thing I want to say is our personal stories exist in a broader narrative ecosystem. And in the United States there is an expectation that we can narrate challenging experiences
当然，它们很难，当然，你感觉不好。我想说的第二件事是，赋予这些经历意义有各种各样的方法。所以我们可能会考虑探索自主或共融的主题。如果你失业了，你是否感到与配偶或孩子的联系，或者你知道如果发生了具有挑战性的事情，是否可能会带来某种成长。所以我们可以探索这些主题。但我想说的第三件事是，我们的个人故事存在于一个更广泛的叙事生态系统中。在美国，人们有一种期望，即我们可以用一种具有救赎色彩的转折来叙述生活中的挑战性经历
in our lives with a redemptive spin. We Americans love the theme of redemption, and we expect people to be able to do it. And I call this the press for redemption. And in my work with Health Story Collaborative, we often find that people feel like they're having this double whammy experience where, you know, I'm sick and I'm not telling the right kind of story about it. So, my cancer didn't teach me that I'm such a fighter or that people love me more than I ever would have realized if I never had cancer.
。我们美国人热爱救赎的主题，我们期望人们能够做到这一点。我称之为对救赎的催逼。在我和“健康故事合作社”的工作中，我们经常发现人们觉得他们有一种双重打击的体验，你知道，我生病了，而且我没有讲述关于它的正确类型的故事。所以，我的癌症并没有教会我，我是一个多么顽强的斗士，或者人们比我从未得癌症时所能意识到的还要爱我。
No, some people say, you know, this just sucks. And I think in those instances, we want to acknowledge that and not try to convince them that it doesn't just suck. Let them know that there's a reason they feel like they're telling the wrong kind of story because our culture puts a particular premium on a particular kind of story and then to help them find other kinds of narrative roots that might lead towards a sense of meaningfulness, even if they can't make you feel better. So many of the examples we've talked about here have involved individuals, but as we've
不，有些人会说，你知道，这简直糟透了。我认为在那种情况下，我们应该承认这一点，而不要试图说服他们这并不糟透了。让他们知道，他们觉得自己讲错了故事是有原因的，因为我们的文化对某种特定类型的故事给予了特殊的重视，然后帮助他们找到其他可能通往有意义感的叙事根基，即使这些根基不能让你感觉更好。我们这里谈论的许多例子都涉及个人，但正如我们
started to see, I think, towards the end of this conversation, we're slowly broadening out beyond the individual, because of course these ideas are relevant outside of individual minds as well. So societies tell themselves narratives, nations tell themselves stories all the time. Do you think ideas of narrative psychology speak to how nations talk to themselves and perhaps how they ought to talk to themselves? I do. And this is really at the forefront of the field. So my colleagues Kate McLean and Moines Sayed have written really compellingly about what they
开始看到的，我想，在这段对话快结束时，我们正在慢慢超越个人，因为当然这些思想在个人头脑之外也同样适用。因此，社会会给自己讲述叙事，国家一直在给自己讲述故事。你认为叙事心理学的思想是否说明了国家如何与自己对话，以及它们也许应该如何与自己对话？我是这么认为的。这确实是该领域的前沿。因此，我的同事凯特·麦克莱恩和莫因·赛义德对他们
call master narratives. So these are the dominant storylines in our culture that tend to be invisible, but also ubiquitous and sort of rigid and powerful. And we are always in a constant dialogue with the master narratives in our particular cultural context. You know, families have narratives that guide the way relationships unfold, and as you said, countries certainly do. So, again, narratives are not all good or all bad at the individual level, and they're not all good or all bad at the at the national level either. But these
称之为“主导叙事”的概念进行了非常引人入胜的写作。这些是我们文化中倾向于隐形但又无处不在、且某种程度上死板而强大的主流故事情节。我们一直在与特定文化背景中的主导叙事进行持续的对话。你知道，家庭有指导关系发展的叙事，正如你所说，国家肯定也有。所以，再次强调，叙事在个人层面并非全好或全坏，在国家层面也并非全好或全坏。但这些
national narratives are emergent from the collection of individual narratives that the members of that country tell. So a number of years ago Jonathan when you were still living in Illinois, the junior senator from your state gave a memorable speech of the 2004 Democratic National Convention. I want to play you a clip from the speech that first put Barack Obama in the National Spotlight. I'm not talking about blind optimism here. The almost willful ignorance that thinks unemployment will go away if we just don't think about it. Or health care crisis will solve itself if we just ignore it.
国家叙事是从该国成员所讲述的个人叙事的集合中涌现出来的。所以多年前，乔纳森，当你还住在伊利诺伊州时，你所在州的年轻参议员在2004年民主党全国代表大会上发表了一场令人难忘的演讲。我想给你播放一段演讲的剪辑，正是这段演讲首次将巴拉克·奥巴马推上了全国聚光灯下。我在这里谈的不是盲目的乐观。那种近乎执拗的无知，认为只要我们不去想它，失业就会消失。或者认为只要我们无视它，医疗危机就会自行解决。
That's not what I'm talking about. I'm talking about something more substantial. It's the hope of slaves sitting around of fire singing freedom songs. The hope of immigrants setting out for different distant shores. The hope of a young naval lieutenant bravely patrolling the Meikang Delta. The hope of a mill worker's son who dares to defy the odds. The hope of a skinny kid with a funny name who believes
这不是我在谈论的。我在谈论更实质性的东西。那是奴隶们围坐在火堆旁唱着自由之歌的希望。那是移民们驶向不同远方海岸的希望。那是年轻海军中尉在湄公河三角洲勇敢巡逻的希望。那是磨坊工人工儿打破逆境的希望。那是那个有着滑稽名字的瘦弱男孩的希望，他相信
that America has a place for him, too. I hope in the face of difficulty. Hope in the face of uncertainty. The audacity of hope. In the end, that is God's greatest gift to us, the bedrock of this nation, a belief in things not seen, a belief that there are better days ahead.
美国也有他的一席之地。面对困难时的希望。面对不确定性时的希望。希望的无畏。最终，那是上帝赐予我们的最伟大礼物，是这个国家的基石，是对未见之物的信仰，坚信美好的日子还在后头。
I'm wondering, Jonathan, as someone who has studied narrative psychology for a number of years, how do you hear that speech? So then Senator Obama was tapping into the American master narrative of redemption, right? Each of those images includes this shift from negative to positive. And you know, like all political speeches, this was a strategic communication with with very particular aims focused on stirring the public to support this speaker's preferred
乔纳森，作为一个研究叙事心理学多年的人，我想知道你是如何听到那场演讲的？当时的参议员奥巴马正在触及美国关于救赎的主导叙事，对吧？那些形象中的每一个都包含了从消极到积极的转变。你知道，像所有政治演讲一样，这是一次战略沟通，有着非常明确的目标，旨在激起公众支持这位演讲者倾向的
candidates and issues. So appealing to entrenched master narratives is a very strategic thing to do, and many, many politicians adopt redemptive themes in their speeches. And obviously there are many wonderful aspects of that storyline, and as we've discussed problematic ones too, but we see evidence of leaders serving as narrators in chief. They shape our narrative ecology as they model storytelling for us. We started this conversation, Jonathan, by talking about ways in which you came to understand the life events in your own life and to tell stories about
候选人和议题。因此，迎合根深蒂固的主导叙事是一件极具战略意义的事情，许多许多政治家都在演讲中采用了救赎主题。显然，那个故事情节有许多美妙的方面，正如我们所讨论的，也有充满问题的一面，但我们看到领导人充当总叙事者的证据。他们在为我们示范讲故事的过程中塑造了我们的叙事生态。乔纳森，我们开始这场对话时，谈到了你如何理解自己生活中的事件，并以一种更积极而非消极的方式讲述
those life events in a way that was more positive than negative. I'm wondering after all these years of studying narrative psychology, do you do this on a regular basis now? What are the stories you tell yourself today in terms of where you are and where your life is and where you want your life to go? So it's not that I am consciously going through my daily experiences and editing them into the kinds of storylines that I have learned are likely to support my well-being. But when difficult things happen in particular, I think I do pause and I remember that there
这些生活事件的故事。我想知道在研究了多年叙事心理学之后，你现在是否会定期这样做？就你所处的位置、你的生活以及你希望生活走向何方而言，你今天对自己讲述的故事是什么？所以，并不是说我有意识地经历日常体验，并将它们编辑成我所了解的可能支持我幸福感的故事情节。但特别是当困难事情发生时，我想我确实会停下来，并且我记得
are different kinds of well-being and that the way I make sense of those experiences will lead me to different kinds of well-being. But I think for a lot of people just the awareness that you are not only the main character in your story, but also the narrator, and that the way you choose to tell the story of your life really matters, that can be an empowering insight. matters that can be an empowering insight.
存在着不同种类的幸福感，我对这些经历的理解方式将引导我走向不同种类的幸福感。但我认为对于许多人来说，仅仅意识到你不仅是自己故事的主角，也是叙事者，而且你选择讲述人生故事的方式真的很重要，这可能是一种赋予力量的洞察。重要，这可能是一种赋予力量的洞察。
Jonathan Adler is a psychologist at Olen College. Jonathan, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, it's been an incredible pleasure. Thank you for inviting me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Anson Kiro, we bring you a story from our sister's show My Anson Kiro. The story comes from listener Rich Addison. So when I was young I was very shy. I was an only child who was pretty comfortable talking to adults, but I never had any brothers and sisters to practice on.
乔纳森·阿德勒是奥林学院的心理学家。乔纳森，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。哦，这真是令人难以置信的荣幸。谢谢你邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里吉特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷勒、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。今天的“无名英雄”环节，我们为你带来一个来自我们姊妹节目《我的无名英雄》的故事。这个故事来自听众里奇·艾迪生。所以当我年轻的时候，我非常害羞。我是个独生子女，和成年人说话时挺自在的，但我从来没有兄弟姐妹可以用来练习。
So I wasn't very good at kind of mixing it up with the other kids. And I remember being very anxious about going to school. And on Sunday nights, I would not be able to sleep just worrying about what would happen with the other kids. So now, flash forward a few years, and I'm in high school. And I realized that I had to be different, that I couldn't keep being so shy. So I went about developing a quick wit and a sense of humor that would keep other kids off balance. So I wouldn't have to feel powerless.
所以我很不擅长和别的孩子们打成一片。我记得我对上学感到非常焦虑。星期天晚上，我会因为担心和其他孩子会发生什么而无法入睡。所以现在，时间快进几年，我上高中了。我意识到我必须改变，我不能一直这么害羞下去。于是我开始培养机智和幽默感，以此来让其他孩子们保持距离。这样我就不必感到无能为力了。
You know how sometimes people say the best defense is a good offense. Well, that was what I was doing. But the sense of humor I developed was kind of biting and kind of critical. So now my hero is about to come into the story. And this was my friend Holly. And one day Holly and I were talking and she said to me, you know, rich, sometimes you really hurt people's feelings. And at first I was just shocked. I said to myself, that can't be true. I was entertaining. I made people laugh. I liked people. These were my friends.
你知道有时人们会说最好的防御就是进攻。好吧，这就是我当时在做的。但我培养出的幽默感有点刻薄，也有点批判性。所以现在我的英雄即将出场。这就是我的朋友霍莉。有一天，霍莉和我正在谈话，她对我说，你知道，里奇，有时你真的会伤害别人的感情。起初我简直惊呆了。我对自己说，那不可能是真的。我很风趣，我逗笑别人。我喜欢别人。这些都是我的朋友。
I didn't want to hurt them. I couldn't be hurting them. But I kept thinking about what Holly said and I kept turning it over in my mind. And eventually I realized that she was absolutely right. And I started paying attention to how my humor was affecting other people. And I changed it. It didn't happen immediately. It didn't happen overnight. But I changed, and I wanted to be more compassionate towards people. And I wanted to have a different kind of relationship with them than always keeping them off
我不想伤害他们。我不可能在伤害他们。但我一直在思考霍莉的话，并在脑海里反复琢磨。最终我意识到她绝对是对的。我开始关注我的幽默是如何影响其他人的。我改变了它。这并没有立即发生。它不是一夜之间发生的。但我改变了，我想对人们更有同情心。我想与他们建立一种不同的关系，而不是总是让他们保持
balance. So after I went on to become a clinical psychologist and in my role I try to help other people have generous interpretations about themselves and others and I've also made a career out of training physicians to do that. And I really am so grateful that I made that shift in my life. And I really owe it to Holly. And I think back to that time so many years ago, and when she cared enough to say something to me, something that probably wasn't easy to say, but it was something that changed the direction of my life
距离。所以在后来我成为了一名临床心理学家，在我的角色中，我试图帮助其他人对自己和他人产生宽容的解读，我也把培训医生这样做作为我的职业。我真的很感激我在生活中做出了这种转变。我真的要感谢霍莉。我回想起多年前的那个时刻，当她足够在乎而对我说了一些话时，这些话可能并不容易说出口，但它却以一种非常显著且令人欣慰的方式改变了我人生的方向
in a very significant and very gratifying way. So, thank you, Holly, you're my unsung hero. Rich Addison lives in Santa Rosa, California. Recently, he was able to reconnect with Holly and tell her how much her comment has meant to him some 50 years later. If you found this episode to be interesting or useful, please share it with someone who you think would enjoy it. If they don't know how to find us, either on podcast apps or their local public radio station, please show them how to do so.
。所以，谢谢你，霍莉，你我的无名英雄。里奇·艾迪生住在加利福尼亚州圣罗莎。最近，他得以重新联系到霍莉，并告诉她，在大约50年后的今天，她的评论对他的意义有多重大。如果你觉得这一集有趣或有用，请把它分享给你认为会喜欢它的朋友。如果他们不知道如何在播客应用或当地公共广播电台找到我们，请告诉他们如何做到这一点。
I'm Shankar Vedanthan. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦达姆坦。回头见。你本集节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。